the vision we have at the center is to
develop technology to help people live
independently and for that we are
thinking of various systems to help you
perception capability the cognitive
capability and mobility capabilities
this technology is something that gives
one the newfound capabilities or
preserves capabilities and that in
itself might have a more profound effect
on their quality of life because they
feel better about themselves and what
they can do one of the very important
activities within the center is what we
call person and society thrust we have a
group of people who work with us to
connect us with the users and evaluate
what we're trying to do and what we have
done from users point of view quality of
life technology really couldn't be done
anywhere else than here because of the
assets that we have because of the
assets within the university one of the
things that we would love to see happen
is that there is a contribution from
every department on campus and so a way
to seed these new types of interactions
between and among the various
researchers particularly ones who
haven't yet gotten involved that's a
part of our recipe for not just growth
but successful growth well the societal
needs for quality of life technology is
obvious the world is getting older
unless we have technological advancement
to reduce the cost to make it make the
help accessible by everybody
the situation will be worsen we have a
leadership position now and to advance
that position and become a really a
global presence in creation and then
commercialization of these new
technologies that's part of our
opportunity that's part of our destiny I
believe
you